hello and take a welcome to the video
playing Bella's Bellas from Norway okay
not quite sure why I played nine and
three first anyway Queens gambit with
Bishop f4 has one of my pet lines that i
have on the board rather often be six
yeah this is a somewhat underestimated
line I believe that black can play
without any big issues okay I don't 95
here Oh takes that interesting hmm ok
huh not quite sure how I want to capture
probably with this hmm ok now that that
importantly for some it's not not that
grade we'll see I think here I mean a
threatening Bishop age 6 here and not so
easy to deal now with this maybe bishop
CA doesn't move ok didn't didn't go for
that i can go east 6en this position
it's mainly quite interesting let's see
if this is so this is good if he takes
it even Knight takes e4 comes into
consideration this one oh that I didn't
expect was thinking the route 37 is a
bit too too dangerous we'll see yeah
it's not threatening to take this as the
thing as I have a huge huge fork okay so
i can take on you for with the night one
option hmm i wonder if f 5 as a move for
him maybe i'm not quite sure so i'm
going to cover this for just for
Security's sake mmm maybe that was a bit
lame but shouldn't be a bad move um can
you go f5 somehow try to play Bishop f6
rookie 6 I have a hard time to believe
that but maybe he can
now this is a good move by threatening
walk c7 now
and 25 both should be pretty pretty good
it's double threat maybe still Bishop f6
Roxy 726 is Sir miraculously holding
you
hmm yeah but you have six I don't see it
wind yet against this even though it
looks pretty bad Lucas is seven queen is
six look Dee sexy maybe this is just
winds up to six I have some doubts with
my background but ok is attacking the
rook at the end this is funky but I can
take this i can take this first what
does he play looking at rook takes no no
then I have Bishop f4 ok and I remained
a piece up ok and Bishop g3 I can yeah
you should be for you there's a piece up
or I do I have something better Luke
texts six is also not bad rooks is six
Bishop g3 rookie sex is also a piece
that looks pretty good push it back
fault so I was winning I guess black
resides yeah that was a bit I don't know
it looks looked a bit loose here all
this after he six I think he has to
react differently yeah this is this is
I'm plus four computers typically
merciless yeah I could have played look
c7 here even I didn't see that at the
point I was just seeing this this tech
piling up but it is not as clear as rook
c7 immediately here you can still
continue with Queen a six even though
this should be very very dangerous age
for strong and this okay I hope was okay
now again this is winning now we had
this this was also okay but this is the
cleanest the cleanest way to do it just
a piss-up in this yeah ending efforts
and ending on already okay there was a i
think a decent game thanks for watching
guys